this is a global news special
presentation
[Music]
welcome to our global news special
virtual town hall with provincial health
officer dr bonnie henry and bc health
minister adrian dicks we are doing this
once again because we are now
approaching two years of this pandemic
and so they have graciously agreed to
join us to answer your questions tonight
and we'll let everybody know we're
broadcasting on bc1 ckw radio and also
on facebook live and we want to thank
the hundreds of people who submitted
questions many covered similar themes so
we hope to get to as many as possible
during the next 60 minutes all right so
let's get right into those by first
talking about the highly contagious new
variant omicron that's right joanne from
victoria says that she knows 15 people
with kovid who all tested privately
and are not part of the official case
count so she wants to know how accurate
can your case count be at this point is
the hospitalization number specifically
now the one to watch
yeah so perhaps i'll start with that one
and uh the answer is yes we've been
trying to actually move away from the
daily case counts for a while it's one
piece of information that helps us
understand the trends of what's
happening over time and it is still
important it's important more to look at
the seven day rolling average and we've
been reporting on that for some time
because that's based on our pcr testing
so that is standard and has been the
same all along and that's the one thing
that helps us with what we call
surveillance is
measuring the same thing over time and
that helps you tell what the trends are
but you're absolutely right and i've
said this in the last
number of weeks when we have a really
highly infectious
variant like the one like omicron it's
it's a whole new game because it spreads
very rapidly so we can't do it's just
not physically possible to do that case
and contact tracing like we did before
and so many people are getting infected
that we just do not have the capacity
and this is a global problem we have a
certain amount of capacity for lab
testing and ours was about 20 000 pcr
tests a day and we can't go beyond that
it's just not possible so that's why we
have to change our approach to how we're
looking at this new variant and how it's
spreading in our communities and all of
us have to be proactive and i think um
you know the experience that this person
has in victoria about knowing that many
people i think that is going to be the
common thing
it probably is already for most of us at
least in victoria in
the lower mainland where we know lots of
people now who have this
and it's going to go through very
quickly the one thing we have on our
side is that we have a lot of people
vaccinated in bc which means that for
most people it's going to be a very mild
illness
but these are all things that are
changing right now and we look at other
things that help us understand the
trends that are happening as well so
those daily case counts are really a
subset of of people who are getting sick
we also have monitoring of
hospitalizations that is really
important because that tells us how many
people are getting seriously ill and
that's one of the important things we
need to watch we also have wastewater
surveillance we do things like we
monitor the percent positivity we do
have an online reporting for people who
are
using the rapid test where you can
report your results and those are
separate but we do watch that as well
and it gives us another sense of what's
happening in different places
you know the hospitalization numbers are
you concerned
obviously our health care system is very
stretched and i'll let the minister
doctor that as well
so
any additional burden is a very much a
challenge right now because we're not
only dealing with people
needing hospital care and some of that
is is still from delta and some of it's
from omicron but we're also dealing with
um
with healthcare workers who are ill
thankfully because they're all
vaccinated most of that is mild illness
but it does put an additional strain on
the system and minister i know that's
right and and you know there's two
things we look at we look at the
hospitalization number and those in
critical care you see what's happening
quebec and ontario where those numbers
have gone up more quickly than we have
right now but obviously we're concerned
that we may be some period behind them
but we look at the overall numbers as
well and those we have some control over
so the number of covet cases in in
hospitals increased significantly in the
last week and we're dealing with that by
reducing
where we have the option and it's a
difficult choice non-urgent scheduled
surgeries such that there are fewer
people in hospital today than there were
on friday because we have reduced the
number of other procedures but there's a
limit to how you can do that january is
typically a very busy time of year
typically in the pre-covet period it
would be a time when we'd be over an
over 100 capacity so we're working on
this and we've been planning on this for
weeks it's why when we made the
announcement two weeks ago that we were
canceling non-urgent elective surgeries
as of our three weeks ago now as of
january 4th
that
that we were planning and preparing for
what might come and so it's it's a very
significant challenge for our health
care workers and especially so since as
dr henry said we have a number of
healthcare workers now a significant
number everywhere long-term care
community care home care
in public health and uh and in acute
care who are themselves sick so that
that reduces our ability to care for
people well and maybe that sort of
starts to answer our next question which
comes from cody um cody wants to know
why are we seeing so many more
restrictions when this is
the mildest variant we've seen those are
cody's words we have talked about how
omicron we believe is um not as severe
as the other variants but why more
restrictions given that omicron seems to
be less
severe
yeah and you know that's uh these are
the things that i started to talk about
when we first
found out about omicron you know how how
quickly was it transmitted what was the
incubation period were more people more
likely to have breakthrough infections
were people more likely to get
re-infected and all of those things are
things that we are now learning and one
of the critical ones was severity of
illness so yes we are now
globally and here in bc
seeing that the illness from omicron is
not as severe as delta in particular
so
part of that is because so many people
have protection from vaccination
but the other part of it of course is
that it spreads that much more quickly
so even if a very small percentage of
people need hospital care the fact that
so many numbers of people are getting
sick means that that number of people
needing hospital care can be
can be overwhelming to the system so the
restrictions are to do a couple of
things we cannot stop this virus and
we've known that for a long time now and
particularly one that is this infectious
and is spreading this rapidly
so we have to try and flatten the curve
and spread out the the amount of people
who need hospital care over time
the other thing that i think is really
really important is
this is a different game as i've said
because of the way it's spreading so
quickly and the fact that there are more
breakthrough infections so people who
are vaccinated are able to get infected
they mostly have mild illness but they
can spread it to other people so people
who aren't vaccinated what we are seeing
is they do still have that same risk of
having more severe illness and needing
hospital care and right now they're not
they don't have that buffer that
protection from infection
that the rest of us gave them from being
vaccinated so if you're not vaccinated
right now your risk has gone up a lot of
getting infected and
having more severe illness in needing
hospital care so you have to take extra
precautions
shell
one of our viewers wants to know if
there's a way to tell the difference
between a common cold or flu or any
other malady you may be getting and
omicron
also what do you think about n95 masks
and their place in helping prevent the
uh exposure and transmission of this
virus
yeah so the the answer around the first
is
it's very difficult and especially you
know people have milder illness this uh
omicron variant attaches more readily to
the the ace2 receptors we call them in
the back of the throat and the nose in
the upper airways so you can have those
runny nose runny eyes sneezing
but we are also seeing that younger
people also get you know headaches and
the muscle legs and feeling tired and
run down as well and cough and all of
those other things but early on it's
very difficult to tell the difference so
that is why with the testing limitations
we have and the the way this is moving
so quickly the really the best thing to
do is if you have those symptoms stay
away from others and particularly stay
away from people who
are at risk of having more severe
illness and
that's the best thing you can do we know
now as well that this is a shorter
duration of illness especially in people
who are vaccinated they tend to have
milder illness for a shorter period of
time so if you can five days is the best
and then wearing masks around other
people if you have any concerns at all
that's important um
yeah you know respirators n95 masks they
have a very specific and important role
in healthcare and in healthcare they
need to be fit tested so that we know
they're they're providing that adequate
barrier and yes they are important when
you have
people who are known to have covid and
we see them used a lot right now and
especially in you know merged
departments in our icus
and in covid wards where we know there
are sick people with covet and there's
virus in that environment
where there's less evidence that they
have
you know that
incremental benefit is in those short
transactional um
settings that we have like going to the
grocery store where you're around people
for a small period of time you can move
away you can keep your distance and
wearing a decent
three-layer mask that fits well to your
face that you're wearing properly which
means over your nose and your your chin
and your breathing through it
you know the the the added advantage
that you get in those types of the
situation from an n95 is probably not
worth it for most people um if you are
somebody who's immune compromised or
your uh you have other risks and you're
around people
where you don't know
them you don't know their vaccine status
you don't know if they're sick or not
then
you can make that choice to wear a
good quality medical mask and one of the
things that we're seeing is that you can
help your medical mask fit better by
wearing a cloth mask over it and it just
fits it better to your face
or
some of the n95 masks
just out of curiosity what kind of mask
do you wear dr henry
i i wear a nice good quality three layer
mask
that fits has a nose piece that fits
over my nose and it fits well to my face
and under my chin
so that's the one i use mostly
okay all right
i'm sure we would have seen it during
the briefings but uh let's move on to
another popular topic in our inbox
today of course first day for kids going
back to the classroom after an extended
holiday break and we have lots of
questions from concerned parents and
teachers so let's start with virginia
virginia says dr tam has said schools
are a source of transmission and many
infectious disease specialists are
saying omicron may be as infectious as
the measles so given that
when elementary schools have so many
unvaccinated and partially vaccinated
children how safe are they and i'm going
to pull a richard zusman here and ask a
second part for kids who may only have
that one shot or who don't have any
shots yet how long should they isolate
if they have coveted or symptoms of
covid
okay
so the first one is
you know i i think it's very clear that
this is not measles
and we can tell that by the pattern of
of outbreaks the patterns of
transmission that we're seeing so it's
it's not measles um you know measles is
a very highly contagious virus it lasts
in the air for long periods of time
we're not seeing the same types of
outbreaks that we see with measles and
yes there are um
you know we're seeing it transmitted
more readily um particularly in those
indoor closed settings when you're not
wearing masks and with your with family
when you're doing things together in
your social networks and your social
gatherings and obviously we've seen a
dramatic increase when schools were not
in session here
we also know that you have multiple
layers of things in schools that make
them as
safe as it can possibly be
obviously there's no situation in our
community anywhere where there's no risk
of of being exposed to covet and
contracting it yourself but we know that
from all of the experience we've had
over the last two years that schools are
the lower risk of a lot of
different places that we can be so
the things that that make it that way
are you know we screen people out to
make sure that there isn't
a lot of people with covet in those
environments we have spent a lot of time
and effort around reformulating
classrooms making sure there's
ventilation paying attention to mask
wearing and making it a positive
experience for children i know that's a
challenge for some children and they're
doing amazingly at it and we know that
for the vast majority of of the exposure
events that we've had in classrooms
where kids have actually been sick in
class or staff have been sick and in a
classroom we don't get transmission we
don't get what we see with measles for
example and we don't expect that to be
any different with this
yes there are going to be children who
who get coveted they're going to be
staff who get covered the vast majority
of them like healthcare workers are
going to be because we're part of
society and we have social networks and
we have family and we have people that
we're around and
you know that the risk
benefits of being in school are just so
much more
benefit of being in class and managing
those risks as best we can and i know
educators are doing that every single
day and my hat's off to them because i
know this is so so important for our
children just the the follow-up to that
for children who are not vaccinated or
only have one shot so far what is your
guidance on
isolating if they have symptoms
yeah so
you know kids tend to have mild symptoms
anyway and there's a whole lot going
around so yes parents know their kids
and and if they have symptoms you know
keep them at home um and for everybody
who's who's vaccinated for everybody
we're really looking at that five day
period but for children it can be really
mild and if it's if it's mild and it
goes away in one or two days then then
they're fine to go back to school
okay all right we swear we're going to
bring the health minister in in a moment
but as a as a father
no problem
well yeah and you'll appreciate no
problem you'll appreciate this this
question too adrian because it involves
basketball as the father of a great
fiverr who is desperate to play um we
got a question from bill who asks will
the province be restricting school
sports during this time and and i'll add
what is the what's the metric to to
figure out when those restrictions will
end
do you want me to start
the restrictions are
just so everyone understands the
restrictions
are provincial health orders that are
made by dr henry and they're and she and
her team do an exceptional job working
through that and finding that balance
and i i can tell you chris and everyone
asks this question all the time like why
this area or this restriction all of
them require a lot of thought and in
every case the consequences of those
restrictions whether they be for a
business or for a young person who might
be playing their grade 12 basketball
tournament in a year or so on so forth
all of that is considered as well and
i'll throw it over to dr henry yeah so
we have tried from the very beginning
recognizing how important
sports and arts and music are for young
people in their growth and development
and learning
so
that has been sort of
same with schools you know the the the
last to close and the first to open
again um so i we don't have any
intentions of restricting
more so than what's in place now so yes
right now
we don't want a whole bunch of kids
coming together over multiple days and
having tournaments
so that's kind of out but playing games
and especially in your local region
absolutely and
that's
something we're not going to put any
additional restrictions on what we see
in schools right now
those are all parts of the the whole
learning experience in schools um and
the the criteria that we're using really
the the things that are in place right
now and i intentionally put shorter
expiry dates if you will or dates of
reassessment on these
because
part of it was to learn more about what
we're seeing with omicron and part of it
was to see you know how one of the
things we are learning is that the peak
tends to be higher and it comes down
more quickly so if we start to see that
then as soon as we can we'll be taking
away these restrictions
um and right now you know we're still on
that that high up peak um
but if we follow trajectories that we're
seeing in other parts of the world we
will start to see that coming down very
shortly and so that is one of the things
that would be watching really carefully
obviously the other one is you know do
we have enough in place that's that's
trying to allow as much as possible to
continue
um and
not overwhelm our health care system so
right now i don't foresee doing
additional
restrictions and hopefully the over the
next couple of weeks we're going to see
a real change in the trajectory of what
we're seeing right now with omicron
he's hoping
all right linda wants to know how do you
justify letting government workers work
from home but not teachers and students
dr henry there's some
there's a
minister can talk to this too i mean
obviously there's some government
workers that can't work from home
there's some jobs that require people to
to be in person and and we've learned
this over this last little while how
many people really are essential for us
functioning whether it's grocery store
workers or pharmacies or
gas stations the person who collects
garbage these are all important
essential things that keep us going so
some government workers are able to work
remotely some of us go into the office
every day or other places
and it's the same with with school staff
and teaching you know in classroom
learning at all levels is important for
not just intellectual growth but
emotional growth physical growth our
interaction in society and and you know
that is
such a critical important role that that
educators play and it is our future um
so it is
part of
how we try and get through this together
is by doing as much as we can
to to keep those important functions
going
and it should tell us how much we should
respect our essential workers as well i
mean we did put in as you know
a mandatory vaccination requirement in
health care something other problems
didn't do we did it here in bc and it
wasn't because we don't love and respect
our health care workers we do because it
was necessary because of the
circumstances of their jobs it's
necessary in education as much as
possible
to have in-class learning and one of the
things that we've achieved in bc and
it's not my achievement or the
government's achievement it's our
achievement it's teachers it's education
assistance it's administrators it's
students themselves and parents and
everyone who made this happen and the
cost of not having that over this
pandemic that is now you know we're
going through second anniversaries the
second anniversary of the first time uh
dr henry and i uh
met on this question was this week
this has had a huge impact so we make
these decisions and all of those that
have to work in person had to throughout
the pandemic healthcare workers without
without change our first responders
without change our grocery store workers
many people and who provide essential
links and transportation it should make
us respect them even more for all they
have delivered for all of us during the
pandemics so these aren't easy decisions
but
of course and and people have made real
sacrifices and we should respect them we
should also celebrate what we've done
together
yeah no doubt and i think it's
you know it's mostly universal right we
are so pleased and thankful for all that
essential workers have done
we got a lot of questions about children
and the vaccine probably no surprise and
christina asks
what is the effectiveness of only one
dose in children five to twelve what is
the efficacy
specifically to one dose of the vaccine
for children in that age bracket
yeah good question um so we know from
the studies that were done that you
start to build your immune response and
you get a good uh high level about three
weeks but of course they were given in
the studies a second dose at about three
weeks so
we know that the uh the vaccine
effectiveness and the efficacy from the
studies are both really high in the high
90s
by the time
you're two weeks past dose two it's very
hard to know one dose but we know that
at least one dose gets that your immune
system prime to look specifically for
the spike protein of the virus and so
your immune system has an advance
warning essentially if you get exposed
to the virus you you have those
antibodies for the specific part of the
virus that binds to the cells so we know
it gives some protection um it's not
perfect and we can see it from in adults
the vaccine effectiveness after a single
dose is in the 50 to 60 range we expect
it would be similar for for children as
well but it is um it is that balance as
well it takes time for your immune
system to develop the the cell mediated
the memory part of the immune system and
that's why it's important to give enough
time for that to mature
before we give the second dose so that
you can get longer and stronger lasting
protection and we we've seen that
in adults where we
extended the interval to make sure we
could get really good protection in most
people and it showed that you get much
better longer lasting protection if you
give that immune system more time and
that's why we're
the interval for children is also at
eight weeks
so that actually might answer our next
question
okay yes wanted to know if you're
considering shortening the length of
time between the two doses for children
in order to get more families completely
vaccinated and i gather from your last
answer that that would be no yeah
so no it's a matter of if you give the
doses too soon you just don't give your
immune system enough time to really get
a good strong i call it mature response
in the the second part so you develop
antibodies and then when you get the
second dose those antibodies go up again
but they they go down over time and
that's the way the immune system works
if we had antibodies in our blood to
everything that we've got immunity to
our blood would be sludge so those
proteins need to they do go down over
time but if the cells your memory cells
your b cells in your t cells those are
the ones that give you long lasting
protection and it takes time for that to
happen so
it really is better to have a little bit
longer interval between dose one and
dose two you're going to get good
protection and with every dose in that
first couple of weeks once you get those
antibodies up you do have really strong
protection against event against
infection that onslaught because the
antibodies are there and then as they go
down over time and when you get to eight
weeks you get a nice booster and those
antibodies go right back up again
what about the one the one thing uh the
one thing i'd say is you know it's
really critical that p that children get
their first dose and about a hundred and
fifty one thousand children have
received the first dose so far about a
hundred and eighty eight thousand have
been registered by their parents there
are three hundred forty nine thousand
children five to eleven so i really
encourage people to go on the get
vaccinated website and register their
children they'll get an invitation a
book almost right away and to get
vaccinated because we're right now we're
at about 43 of children vaccinated about
54 percent of children registered and we
would that's that's very good we want it
to be higher and really encourage people
to do it tonight if they can get on the
website register your children tonight
excellent advice um what about the age
group donna wants to know uh the the
children under the age of five when
might the vaccine be made available to
to those kids under the age of five
years old
yeah so so both
moderna and pfizer have been doing
studies in younger children down to six
months of age and before six months of
age
our immune systems aren't really
developed enough to be able to respond
to a vaccine
and i will put in a plug that's why it's
so so important for for pregnant people
to be immunized because
you get the protection and we know
that's really important when you're
pregnant but you also give antibodies to
to the infant and that protects them in
that first few months of life as their
own immune system is developing
but when we talk about six months to to
five years of age there's been some
challenges uh the the initial two dose
vaccine that uh pfizer was working on
showed that it didn't uh have as strong
protection as what we're seeing in the
the five to 11 and the older
children and adults so they've gone back
to the drawing board a little bit so
it's unclear when we're going to have a
vaccine for those younger kids which is
all the more reason why it's important
for all the rest of us or people who are
around younger children to get the
protection themselves
all right this next question comes from
a concerned grandparent and i've heard
this from a lot of families they want to
know that given children under the age
of five are not able to be vaccinated
yet and they spend time in settings like
day cares what is the plan to keep them
safe and i guess not just them but then
their families that they live with
because many of these kids live in
multi-generational homes
yeah and it really is
as i was saying you know both ways um
it's that us protecting those children
because we know younger children can
have more severe illness with uh with
with covida though thankfully for most
of them it's still mild so it is both
things we have
and i i do want to also recognize the
early childhood educators and our
daycare operators because
they also
really important to have those safety
plans in place and we've been working
with them we have updated guidelines
that came out recently so
the most important thing we can do is
all the rest of us be vaccinated that
protects you that protects them
and so older people in
multi-generational families really
important for you to get your booster
shot get vaccinated get your booster
shot that's the best we can do and then
if children are sick making sure that we
try and keep them away from
those who are most at risk
keep them a little bit isolated as much
as you can and i know that's a real
challenge for young children but
maybe stay away from
from people who have immune compromising
conditions especially
all right bc's booster program ramped up
earlier this month in an effort to curb
the spread of the omicron variant a lot
of viewers have questions about the
program and the booster shot itself
things related to timing so let's get to
those now
andrea from chilliwack asks what's the
optimal time to wait after a covet
infection to receive your booster if
you're on the list to get a booster
you know as soon as you're feeling
better and i've had this question from a
number of people you know well why do i
need the booster if i've had the
infection
it's still particularly in people who've
been vaccinated
you know mild infection it may not
stimulate a whole bunch of immune
response and it varies depending on
how sick you are and and everything else
with it so as soon as you're feeling
better go ahead and get your booster
dose
which you know the next question is sort
of again
playing off that you would definitely
say if you have had omicron you should
get your booster anyways what what does
that do to the status of your immunity
to have had both
yeah you know what we are seeing is that
people who've had
vaccine and infection and then get their
booster dose are basically super immune
it really uh gives you really strong
antibody response but also stimulates
those the memory cells again your cell
mediated immunity
so we think that they are the people who
are most protected over time and what
we're really hoping and one of the
reasons and you know this is a question
i get a lot to is why are we still
waiting for six months because we know
that that extra time um really again
gives you longer lasting protection
because we're going to be living with
covid in some form or the other for
quite a long time so we we don't want to
sacrifice our ability to to whether the
next wave um so six months is still
seems like a reasonable time we we were
there's some evidence that even out to
eight months for younger healthier
people was probably gives you longer
lasting stronger protection um but in
terms of you know trying to deal with
what we have going on right now we've
moved it up so everybody gets it at six
months
and that i believe
will
will help us get through this wave but
also for what's coming in the future as
we as we learn to live with this virus
many people have questions about whether
to get pfizer or moderna for their
booster shot should those with pfizer
previously stick with that or should
they switch it up and get modern what's
your best advice
um well i can tell you i'm a fifi mod
so what you call it okay i'm learning
i'm learning the lingo
so
um yes
you know what um both are fine and
that's another thing that canada has
been one of the leaders on is uh is
learning about mixing and matching of
vaccines and how effective that can be
um so
either one is fine i will say there is
some evidence that moderna gives a
stronger longer lasting response even
the the booster dose of moderna is half
of the the regular dose
and even that
has been
shown in some of the studies are very
limited uh in some of the countries that
are sort of ahead of us that moderna
probably is the best um strongest
for a booster but either one is
is really great um so you don't need to
have a pfizer if you've had pfizer you
don't need to have modern if you've had
moderna
take whichever you've got and if you
have the option of getting modern then
go for it and i've had moderna for all
three uh chris so there you go
i don't know
don't know about that but i am
i didn't get madonna
interesting okay uh i don't i meant i'm
double lazy and madurain i don't know
what you'd say what do you call that i
don't you can say it you're an astra mod
all right
um
dr henry uh minister dixon we've had
many questions come to our newsroom
about the vaccine and questions about
whether there have been adverse
reactions in connection with vaccines in
this province and whether there have
been any deaths linked to the vaccine
yes so absolutely we have an adverse
effects called adverse events following
immunization or we call them afes so it
is something that we have a very strong
reporting system in canada and
every province reports it it's part of
an international
group that looks at these across the
world which is one of the reasons we
know
some of the
the very details about
adverse events that can happen after
these vaccines it's also how we picked
up some very rare events like
the
excuse me thrombosite
bit after astrazeneca that happens very
rarely so yes we have had serious
adverse events following immunization
and we call it that specifically because
there are things that happen after
people are immunized that may or may not
be related to the vaccine we've had four
people in british columbia who've had
vit after vaccines that have been caused
by the vaccines we've had a very small
number of people who've had myocarditis
or pericarditis after
receiving a
mrna vaccine
there's
there's been no deaths associated or
directly related to vaccines we have had
a and i'm not i was looking at the
numbers earlier today but it's
a small number in the single digits of
of people who have died within uh 30
days of receiving a vaccine none of them
in investigation have been
directly linked to the vaccine itself
but these are things that we
we follow very carefully
there's a report that's published every
two weeks on the bccdc website and you
can see all the details of all of the
serious adverse events that have
happened
just to just to clarify though dr henry
the number of adverse
effects compared to the number of people
who have been vaccinated in bc
is a very very small percentage
it's it's
less than
less than one half of one percent
you're absolutely right we've had um in
the vicinity of 400
serious adverse events in almost 10
million vaccine doses given in in the
province so yes these are of the safest
vaccines and the most you know one of
the things that was really really
important when we started our vaccine
program was making sure that we recorded
every vaccine that went into everybody's
arms and i know early on there was a lot
of you know how come it's taking us so
long why is it taking us so long to get
pharmacies on board it's because we need
to get every single dose into our
immunization registry so that we can
monitor this safety over time and we
know exactly which lot of which vaccine
people received so we can we can follow
up on any signals that happen around
safety and and that's been really really
important
far more likely to have adverse
reactions to covid than to vaccines it's
become very clear by a factor of ten to
a hundred from there it just is
dramatically
um more
severe illness in across the board from
being infected with covet there you go
let's hope that stat sticks
changes to visitation at long-term care
centers prompted a lot of questions to
clear up some of the confusion there we
got a question from brian who says his
90 year old father in care who asks him
daily when he is coming to visit
he's double vaccinated he's willing to
wear an n95 mask and his question is
were any other options considered before
the restrictions on visitation that the
province put
in fact all of the options i'd say have
been
used if you think about it everyone
everyone working in long-term care
has to be vaccinated everyone visiting
in long-term care has to be vaccinated
we put on a very significant response to
protect people and still
there have been significant issues in
long-term care over time
we just before the christmas period were
down to zero outbreaks in long-term care
because of the omicron
variant of concern we now have dozens
dozens of outbreaks and i know this from
personal experience from our family and
we're going through it right now
is that when an outbreak occurs it has
very significant effects on everyone in
the care home not just on visitation but
on everything else so these measures are
in place in in a short and direct sense
that dr henry has put in place in a
short and direct sense to address the
very significant uncertainty in health
care and to protect people residents of
long-term care and i know personally i
want brian i think the name of your
question was to know that it affects us
personally and we have focused on this
and talked to dozens if not hundreds of
people over the last number of years it
is not anybody's intention for these
restrictions on visitation to last as
they did last year this was a necessary
step
taken to protect people given the
significant
growth and growth and transmission of
the covet 19 the omicron variant of
concern and that's what dr henry and
that's what all of our teams are trying
to do in long-term care
i will say you know it was put in place
at a time coming into the long weekend
when we still had unrestricted numbers
of people that were going into long-term
care and i was getting reports of of a
lot of concern of health care workers
being sick and and not having the
ability to properly screen people so we
are in a transition now to make sure
that we can have that one designated
visitor for every resident it is so so
important and we are going to
make this as short as possible as this
wave comes through here and as i said
you know the the wave is is a lot
sharper and steeper but also moving a
lot more quickly this time
all right marilyn from tawasin asks
given the problems of long-term care
workers infecting residents why is rapid
testing only being used to screen
visitors and given the outbreaks that we
are seeing uh despite visitor
restrictions clearly staff are still an
issue
well well in fact of course as you know
we've brought in mandatory vaccination
long-term care we've been using rapid
testing in long-term care throughout
this year throughout last year 2021 in
fact starting on december 3rd they've
been used in outbreak management they've
been used at different periods in the
interim period in advance of the
mandatory vaccination order being put in
place and they're being used now in the
last since december 21 when we announced
the rapid testing plan 200 000 rapid
tests have been distributed to long-term
care in that period long-term care homes
in that period as well so rapid tests
have been used in long-term care they
are being used in long-term care and
they will be used in long-term care
as well as visitors
i'm not sure that's right visitors
yeah exactly exactly
all right sandy uh another question here
she wants to know when all health care
workers including dentists
physiotherapists and massage therapist
would be required to be vaccinated to
practice is that is that in the works
it is in the works and it's one of those
things where
we're still working with the colleges
about how to make sure we understand the
vaccination status of registrants
excuse me and uh so that's
in the works and we uh
it will be coming soon i did put notice
in the uh
in one of the orders uh just before uh
in november about that um it's been more
complicated a process than we expected
but it is coming
all right uh testing has become
something of an issue again
um with the rise of omicron so we want
to we have a lot of questions about uh
the testing policy in bc joan from trail
asks
why is bc making it impossible to get a
rapid cover test this is what joan
writes
many people would like access to these
tests as a senior i would like a test to
ensure i do not have the virus as an
extra layer of precaution
all right the rapid test question it's
been one that has come up a number of
times
so i'm going to hand it over to dr henry
in a minute the the federal government
is getting a significant number of rapid
tests you might have heard the federal
health minister mr duplo announced
they're getting 140 million of them
in the coming weeks they haven't really
arrived yet so we've received in the
hundreds of thousands and when you think
about those numbers so say our number is
18 million which is about 13 of that 140
million or so is what we would expect to
get 18 million is about three per person
so what we've got is the ones we're
using we're using in priority areas such
as long-term care but also we'll be
using in education in other areas and
then as as we receive more of the rapid
tests that can be used at home because a
significant number of them require a
medical
practitioner to use a significant number
of the ones we have now then we'll be
broadening that out but
when we get them we'll be distributing
them but
what is really important is to take the
actions we can take now and all of those
have been what we've been talking about
the beginning from
reducing our social contacts to washing
our hands to wearing our masks and to
getting vaccinated but uh over to you
doctor yeah you know the rapid tests uh
have been a source of
of angst uh over a long period of time
and they're they have evolved there are
many different types of tests and we've
said this a number of times so the ones
that we had here in bc and in october we
made a decision i made a tactical
decision
that we would wait for the at-home test
that we were expecting to come
in november and they had been delayed
and delayed and we are going to start
getting some of the at-home tests
coming up very soon
but the limited numbers that we had and
they are a limited commodity around the
world so
there unfortunately
we have not ever had enough that we
could give them out to people to use as
they have in in some other countries in
europe for example
we
are hopefully going to be getting a
supply that is more regular that we can
then start using them and and giving
them to people like seniors
so that you can
understand the risk around you and
where our focus is at first is going to
be at schools for symptomatic children
and to help parents make those decisions
about
you know can my child go to school today
i think it's been um
unfortunate that they've been billed in
some parts of this country and other
countries as
as a ticket to to being able to go to
social events and i've said this a
number of times it you know they're very
most helpful if they're positive they're
a red light if they're positive but
they're not a green light to and we've
seen that repeatedly because they're
just not sensitive enough to to say that
you can abandon all of those other
things that are important and yeah i'd
love to be able to have more tests
available so people can can
do their own tests if they have symptoms
to help understand your own risk and we
will get to that i hope with the tests
that are coming in the coming months
tom from south surrey wrote us to ask
well he wants to know how reliable rapid
tests are especially with omicron
circulating as it is maybe specifically
for that variant
you know how accurate are they
yeah we're well that's another one of
those pieces of the puzzle that we're
learning and that omicron affects more
the upper airways and what people are
finding is more likely to get false
positives and false negatives
with this new variant with the nasal
swabs that we're using primarily and
that perhaps
throat swabs or saliva might be more
accurate for
for omicron where it's the exact
opposite for delta where we actually had
very much better results with
having the nasal swabs so these are all
sort of technical things that are being
worked out the bottom and there's a
number of of studies that have shown us
that there's a lot of both false
positives in in low prevalence settings
so where there's not a lot of the virus
around and there's a lot of false
negatives in some of the higher
prevalence so the bottom line is
exactly what i said if it's positive it
tells you something if it's negative it
really doesn't tell you anything at all
uh and we've had many viewers write in
dr henry and minister dix wanting to
know how long you can still test
positive on a pcr test even after you've
recovered from covet 19.
yeah so the pcr tests are actually very
very accurate and they can find pieces
of the of the virus even after you're no
longer infectious to others so it can be
a month six weeks we found that people
are still testing positive although
rarely and generally it's um the the
cycle time is much uh much higher which
means that there's much less of the
virus around so um if we we it's one of
the things that helps us measure if it's
an
acute affection or if it's something
that's just been around for a long time
so it can be for some weeks in some
people
okay bc took some additional measures
last month aimed at curbing the surge of
cases
in the province many viewers are looking
for some clarification though and
help in planning events activities
in the near future
yes physical fitness was a big one in
our email inbox
both of you so neil in vancouver wants
to know if gyms are allowed to stay open
if they're only operating as one-on-one
personal training and if a trainer and
client stick to one pod and don't
interact with others isn't that enough
or safe enough to stay open
so you know
we we try and find that balance of doing
the minimum amount of things that that
are in those higher risk settings and
uh is unfortunately gyms as a
as a setting are places where we've seen
a lot of transmission particularly in
the demographic where we're seeing
omicron cases rising very rapidly um
we're now at a different place uh in
that that demographic is now
decreasing in in terms of transmission
and that age group of people who are are
going to gyms
we have uh
large numbers of our older population
boosted now which means they have
increased protection and the younger age
group is now all getting caught up at
six months with their booster doses so
we're moving into a different place
where i'm i've been working with the
fitness industry so that we can start to
get
gyms back open safely again very soon
viewers say that because of
of gyms and the positive impact on their
mental and physical well-being they
should be considered an essential
service is there any
thought to maybe changing the
categorization of gyms in the future
yeah i do i just say this about these
subjects i think we are and i think dr
henry talked about that but i i would
say this that you know the virus doesn't
really argue with these definitions
our the gym industry the fitness
industry did an exceptional job after we
reopened last year
in ensuring that their gyms were safe
omicron and the nature of its transit
mission has changed the game and changed
the game
uh and the way the virus interacts with
us so the virus isn't interested in our
definitions of things it's interested in
transmitting and the concern and gym
with gyms and with the fitness industry
is that was a place
that the virus could transmit and
transmit fairly easily so that's the
reason the measures were taken but again
i can tell you that every time such a
step is taken
everybody in public health agonizes over
it because it's a very very difficult
call to make that call and to make that
decision we know the impact on people
but
gyms are very important community
centers are very important recreation is
very important so the the extent we can
move on up we will but the reason uh but
i just want to remind everyone that this
is not a virus that debates these
questions with us and so sometimes
actions have to be taken that are
difficult but have benefits for the
whole community and allows us to get
through this more easily and better
a couple of uh gyms quoted in coverage
we had not that long ago though that say
they've had 160 member check-ins 70 000
member check-ins 160 000 member
check-ins and no transmissions in their
gyms what is the evidence you have
that shows that gyms are
a method of transmission
you know i think there's
it's very challenging for somebody
sometimes to let people know that we do
as you know contact racing and we have
many many examples where
that has been the the link between
people um but it's
in a sense it's
it's those environments where we're
doing that type of activity that are
indoors that are higher risk and it is
it is a reality that whether people
realize it or not um that is absolutely
where we have seen transmissions take
place and then it it goes it spreads and
we've we've shown those um you know the
the uh um what are they called the the
transmission maps where
uh there's a couple of cases here and
you know somebody works in long-term
care and then it leads to an outbreak in
long-term care so we have seen that
repeatedly and
there are many settings that are
unfortunately like that
and we've had to take measures whether
it's
many of the worship services where we
put in restrictions whether it's
nightclubs where the whole reason to be
in a nightclub is to be indoors close
together dancing with people and and
those are environments where this virus
just loves it
um moving on from jim's weddings maggie
who is getting married later this month
congratulations maggie wants to know why
she can go to a restaurant to have a
meal with five other people but she
can't have a table of six at her wedding
reception
yeah so again
weddings absolutely funerals those
important um
ceremonies are
we're trying to protect um but those
gatherings right now are the ones uh we
know that it's not just one table of six
and everybody stays at their table like
in a restaurant right now and it and
that's where we're seeing transmission
happen really quickly particularly with
this variant
valerie wrote in from vancouver island
she wants to know why spa and aesthetic
services don't require double
vaccination
and passports at the moment any plans to
change that
yeah no um
you know those are there are coveted
safety plans in place and and they are
are working in those environments um i
absolutely uh strongly encourage all uh
owners and operators of spas and and
personal service settings to make sure
that all of their staff are vaccinated
it protects them it protects your
workforce it protects your workplace
and it protects your business
um
we do have a question we've seen the the
covid situation the restriction
situation dr henry and minister dix
across the country sort of vary
depending on their situations
quebec has brought in this policy of
implementing a vaccine
passport if you want to go to a liquor
store or a cannabis store is that
something you're considering for bc
asking for a friend
named us
it's not something you know when we put
in the bc vaccine card
we looked very much there was two
primary aims one was of course to
encourage people who just couldn't be
bothered to to get vaccinated and the
the second really important one was to
address those
those
what's the word those
places where you don't have to go
where the risk was higher so indoor
settings
where you're doing things like gyms
like sitting close together like uh in a
theater or
another indoor setting so it really was
targeted at those um
those
places that are essential to visit like
grocery stores so you need
groceries that's right yeah the
intention the vaccine card really was to
deal with things that were not essential
but would lead to transmission right and
we saw with the delta variant in
particular its impact on unvaccinated
people we transferred you know 120
people
in critical care with covet 19
out of the north in a period in
september october and november and
december far away from home to get
critical care all of them needing
significant help all along the way so we
brought in the bc vaccine card it has
been massively adopted by people in bc i
mean massively receive not just support
but receive support and being downloaded
in an extraordinary way and i want to
say that it has been successful i think
as an instrument because people have
adopted it and engaged with it and
embraced it and there are exceptions and
those exceptions sometimes get spoken
about but the bc vaccine card has been
effective but we've also taken tough
action that was difficult action in
places where jurisdictions like quebec
haven't like mandatory vaccination and
health care which they wanted to do but
then didn't do we've done that and i
think it's serving us well right now
and the other thing that we considered
was the fact that there's alternatives
so you know you don't have to go to a
movie you don't have to go to the
canucks game you can watch things on tv
there there's
you know you can listen to music and
without going to a theater
so it was where there were alternatives
that people could do as well
i'm just putting it out here and i'm not
advocating for it at all but quebec did
see
a big jump in people registering to get
vaccinated when it became clear they
were going to need a vaccination card to
go to buy those they have a priority
that's right as an incentive
maybe it's
maybe it's effective
they've seen them but i think what's
been effective in bc
92 of people receive their first dose
immunization 90 percent their second
dose
we're closing in on
well over 1.2 million people receive
their booster doses is really getting
vaccinated because it makes you safer it
makes the ones you love safer and makes
your community safer that's a pretty
strong reason to get vaccinated and
where we need to where we can and
employers can it's important that
they're in many cases insisting on
vaccination as we are for example in
health care and in the public service
but i i would say that i think our
approach has been very very successful
compared to basically anyone else in the
world and that's because of british
columbians hard to argue that for sure
if you can answer these last two uh last
questions in 20 seconds each i should
mention though that um mark wrote in
just dr henry to offer to take you
ballroom dancing once this is all over
just so you know
uh but in 20 seconds oh yeah in 20
seconds each what are you most looking
forward to once this is
finally over
you know what i i think like most people
i really am can't wait to travel and i
want to have a good rest you know
well yeah i i think wrestling would be
good i'd like to see mark singing and
dancing in the rain you know i think
that would work well
i'd like to see
chickens maybe maybe they could do a
duet
that's i like that i like that
that's it
one day yeah let's hope that would be a
pleasure
yeah absolutely one day one day we'll
get to it all well thank you so much uh
for being with us once again i've lost
track of how many of these we've done
since the pandemic started but
once again many of our viewers wanted to
say how much they appreciate all you do
for us and acknowledge how difficult
your roles have been over these past two
years so thank you
thank you very much dr henry and adrian
dixon and thanks to everybody watching
on bc1 and facebook live as well there's
a lot and listening on cknw there's a
ton of people working behind the scenes
to make something like this work and we
appreciate what they do especially when
it comes to monitoring some of the
comments we know we get online and
through email and all of that it can be
quite traumatic but
thank you so much again to the two of
you for your time tonight and for
everybody watching at home
hey thank you
good night all and
be kind be calm and be safe as dr henry
always says that's the quote of the
century thanks everybody have a good
night
[Music]
this has been a special presentation
from global news